All right, before we hop into the engine,
we're gonna cover the animation pipelines
from traditional to more of the modern with Unreal Engine.
So normally you would start in your separate DCC program
and you'd model, rig, and animate.
And then once you were finished,
you'd import that finished animation
directly into Unreal Engine.
Now you could take it further into Sequencer,
edit things, add some more tracks to it
from whatever you would want for other reason.
Now, you could also now edit in Sequencer,
the option you would edit with the FK control rig,
or even bake it to an existing control rig
and work on that even further.
Now here's a typical animation studio pipeline.
As you can see, this is very traditional.
You've got everything set up in the different departments
at work alongside, kind of in parallel,
and the very typical setup.
Now the newer in-editor animation pipeline
encourages you to do more within the engine.
And as we add more and more tools,
you're gonna realize you're gonna be able to do
just about everything within Unreal Engine.
Now, currently you have the control rig
and procedural rigging, which is a newer tool set,
where you can build and animate controls
either manually or using procedural rigging,
as it says, as a template.
That means you can actually use that
for multiple types of characters,
different sizes, different bones, or the number of bones.
It's a really great tool,
but this is a new set of tool sets that have been added.
Control rig has been around for a little while,
but it's improving constantly.
Now we also have the sequencer key frame,
where everything in the control rig
is animated within the level sequence.
Now you'd build an empty level, as it states,
and you would work that area
and animate it directly within that scene,
all in live, in real time.
So you'd be able to see what's going on
as you're animating.
You don't have to render it out first.
And there are some newer tools I did wanna mention
that currently they are within experimental stage.
One of them is the skeleton mesh editing tool.
Now this is available via a plugin, as it states.
It is experimental, so it's not production ready.
You'd suggest not using it.
However, here is a link that is included
for that US skeleton editing.
Now here is the newer pipeline.
As you can see, there's some different coloring,
which means it's traditionally done outside of Unreal
and moving more as you see the colors
are becoming darker.
That means it's even more done so within the engine.
So this is a pretty typical new studio pipeline,
utilizing everything within Unreal Engine.